when the nervous system realizes  that the diamond was there the whole  time it just like  goes into shock it's like what it was  there the whole time  i've been seeking externally  for my nature i've been trying to attain  peace and happiness in objects and  experiences  and relationships and substances  and then you [ __ ] laugh at yourself  because you're like  i was so stupid just like in the parable  of the prodigal son  i was so dumb thinking that i would  find peace and happiness  in a dream in an illusion  when in reality the nature of the  [ __ ] observer itself  is peace and happiness  ah  that's the realization that's the cosmic  joke